hoy el Tribunal Superior electoral
reanuda la última sesión en la que
podría condenar a Jair bolsonaro a la
inhabilitación por un periodo de ocho
años el resultado que se espera es de 5
a 2 votan tres jueces entre ellos el
presidente del tribunal Alexandre
dimoráez al que bolsonaro considera un
enemigo personal también vota el juez
lunes Márquez al que bolsonaron nombró
para la Corte Suprema se espera que vote
en contra pero parece que ha desistido
de la idea de pedir una vista previa lo
que habría suspendido el juicio por un
periodo de hasta 60 días bolsonaro
parece resignado y combativo al mismo
tiempo dijo ayer que es un juicio
político cuyo único objetivo es alejarle
de la política para que en 2026 la
izquierda no tenga rivales Mientras
tanto en los bastidores ya se habla de
sucesión se habla de Michelle y
bolsonaro su esposa como posible futura
candidata al lado de la ex ministra de
cultura
Teresa Cristina ahora este juicio de hoy
no es la única preocupación para
bolsonaro su estrecho colaborador
maurosid encarcelado declara hoy ante la
policía federal es considerado su
ayudante en el intento de golpe del 8 de
enero y esto podría traer una
preocupación para bolsonaro maurosid
hacia quedado en silencio en las
anteriores declaraciones pero todo
apunta a que hoy podría hablar